Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos is expected to
unveil plans today for the future of his
space company Blue Origin he tweeted the
first photos of the main engine of his
company's future rocket yesterday it's
designed to take tourists into space and
to the moon chip Reid is at the
Washington DC Convention Center where
Bezos will make the announcement to show
how it could shake up shake up the race
with SpaceX chip good morning good
morning more than 14,000 space engineers
entrepreneurs and enthusiasts are
gathering here to discuss the future of
space and they'll be watching a fierce
competition not between two nations but
between two billionaires in less than a
year space company Blue Origin has
successfully launched and landed its
rocket the new Shepard five-times
touchdown but now the company appears to
be shifting its focus to a familiar
target the moon Blue Origin is
reportedly circulating a seven-page
whitepaper to NASA and the Trump
administration outlining its plan to
develop a new spacecraft to help it
establish human settlements on the moon
what it really wants to do is to land
this lunar to be able to bring cargo
supplies equipment science experiments
and liftoff Bezos target isn't just
Earth's nearest neighbor he's also
aiming at Elon Musk and his rival
company SpaceX to make its shipments
Blue Origin could use its largest rocket
the new Glenn named after John Glenn the
first astronaut to orbit the earth it
will be ready to fly by the end of the
decade capable of directly competing
with SpaceX's Falcon rockets and liftoff
SpaceX has already successfully launched
29 Falcon 9 rocket and also has its eyes
on the moon on a conference call last
week musk announced plans for two
private citizens to ride in a lunar
capsule as early as next year it would
give them the surface of the Moon go
quite a bit further out into deep space
and then live back to it Bezos says he
wants to do that and more our visit
millions of people living working space
the two have enjoyed a friendly rivalry
for years but now those who follow their
careers closely say they're high-stakes
competition could lead to high tech
innovation what these companies want to
do is help create a self-sustaining
economy in space and that's what's
fueling all of this during the Obama
years much of the space community was
focused on getting to Mars but now many
are refocusing on the moon and for Bezos
and musk it is a business opportunity
that's simply out of this world
Gale very well said thank you chip and
both those guys are at the top of their
game - it'll be interesting it's very
exciting to see what they're doing yeah
it's nice to see billionaires play the
game of whose is bigger like it like it
I thank you